[Music]
what up guys welcome back to
off the record with two daddies and a
baby
i like these segments man if you guys
like these let us know in the comments
below
but also hit that like we never say hit
that like button
i found out now that the algorithm is
such [ __ ]
yeah you have to interact you got to
comment you got to hit like you got to
say what's up turn on notifications
the thumbs up not thumbs down thumbs up
yeah you know i'll be going
in the comments too i just i just
respond to people now like i'm i'm in it
i'm in there now
that's dumb yeah like before i don't
know man i feel like og
youtubers didn't use youtube the same
way
that like i don't know it's been some
time you know we just
don't use it the same way yeah now i
think it's more like they're kind of
like mini networks
yeah versus before i think it's just
ways to connect and i think that's what
makes tick tock still feel
kind of pure where just literally it's
like people that are like
hey i have uh adhd anybody else have it
these are this is my
what i experienced and you just
connected and i think that's even how
old youtube was but now it's
like there's channels that the day
they're born as professional
yeah i'm gonna get that brain scan you
did next year i'm gonna schedule it
oh you are yeah i can't i can't wait to
do it i i want to know i'm pr i'm pretty
sure i got adhd
but i want to know i [ __ ] sure i got
there's no way
that i don't because on tick tock i
watched this doctor
um he's a psychologist and he has adhd
and it's tight because he breaks a lot
of things down so one of the things that
he said that really reminded me of you
so every time it cuts to him he's this
old white guy
he's sitting here and his desk is a
[ __ ] mess right
and there's [ __ ] paper stacked and
everything and he goes
to the non-adhd mind you think this is a
[ __ ] mess and he goes but to me
i know where everything is and so uh for
him he goes what people don't understand
with adhd is for a lot of adhd people
if it's out of sight it's out of mind
exactly
yeah so yeah to control the chaos it's
much
easier to just have everything out there
so you know where your [ __ ] is and you
actually know
uh where things are um
but to the other person who doesn't have
it they just go this guy's [ __ ] messy
all the time and i'm like oh that's what
joe is because joe always wants to [ __ ]
everywhere
this wasn't here i'd buy another one
because it's not here yeah uh well you
know what though my room is pretty
[ __ ] clean
now that's dope my bed my bed is always
made everything is
everything is like pristine but i see it
as artwork now
very different perspective but my work
table though
it is pretty nuts it's just that i have
a rule now
to uh attend to it every day
so at the end of the day i have to have
it and then i realized
like when i do this at home it's because
this is actually my open notepad
and it's like i gotta do this and then i
gotta do this
and then i gotta do this i gotta train
this [ __ ] later and then pornhub and
attack yep
it's like open tabs it's it's what all
this [ __ ] is how my brain works too like
when i'm how come you're way more
organized than i am
oh no well afterwards i'm like you i
have a i try to have a rule if i leave
the desk it's got to be clean
oh just cause it's easy to go from
keeping tabs
to an actual mess that's how your car is
too like you said like sucking like you
say you go to a
gas station they have a trash can there
while it's filling up just throw away
the trash
yeah so i try to keep my car like a
rental because uh where it's just
empty all the time because it's really
easy that i noticed for myself
things can go from my workspace to a
literal mess
and then it becomes a mess that builds
on top of each other and the next time
that i have to clean it takes like five
hours i need to be better about that
with my car because my car is just like
a
vessel to travel yeah and then even
though i'm in a lot i'm just like i push
it in the back i put clothes there's
like tripods everything and it's just
like packed always
and i never clean it but then like i go
to my room and like it has now it has to
be like clean
but like earlier what you're saying
about like say the adhd people they can
function
through like that mess where i think it
also gave
a bad impression or not impression but a
bad message to messy people
where they were like smarter people are
actually messier so the mess people are
like yeah [ __ ] yeah you know yeah this
is you
i'm smart you'll be smart but you're not
getting laid yeah that's true but also
it's like it was
the dumb messy people that are just also
messy that are like
yeah it's because i'm smart yeah you
can't tell the difference yeah so they
were like you could just be lazy
are all the stuff in your car is it
because you have to use it all the time
that's why
or it just ended up you were gonna take
it somewhere and it just ended up
leaving in there
uh so like say we have shoes for barbell
i'm the one that brings the clothes and
has to take it back
i don't know where i take it it's just
in my car now
oh do i just throw it in the [ __ ]
office yeah store in the office we're
done shooting yeah and then i'm also
lazy where i'm like i gotta carry
the office now oh i see do you dodge
[ __ ] because you focus
too much on something that should have
been like so for example right like when
you're doing a project
sometimes you should be putting things
away but then it's easy to just toss it
and grab what you need to do and then
get that done you just toss it you grab
whatever
and when you're done with everything
then you put it away but some people
they'll use something and then they put
it back to where it's supposed to be
that's also a sign of adhd
yeah you can't do it yeah because uh
because i'm like that too
so for adhd people um
it's because there there's so many
thoughts
at the same time that you're scared of
putting this back
because if you once you put it back
you're gonna forget your train of
thought
that's what happens that's why i hate
doing that so you have to
just if you have this task it just has
to be this
and then that way you can actually
finish the task because if you put this
away
and you're like oh a roller yeah
i can't be interrupted me too i think i
might
have that yeah but it's like when i'm
doing something i need to finish
then everything starts popping up
otherwise i could focus on tick tock for
hours
but like if i have work and then i'm
like my phone rings and it goes
and then i'm like zoop and then now it's
like i answer that text and then i open
up tick tock you might have it because
for me like jill will be like hey can
you put this one in the garage
i go and then like 30 minutes later
where the hell did you go and i opened
like all the family pictures because
remember this day did i put something on
my head
oh what's that thing
so i'm just like zoned into another
world i'm like that with uh
cooking because like say i use this one
ingredient i'm like i might have to use
it for something else like i keep
organized but i make a pile of mess here
and now i'm getting smarter with it
where it's like i have a bowl
i learned this from rachel ray she
always has a trash bowl a trash bowl so
i don't need to walk to
like say in your kitchen you have to go
over here and open this um
trash bin and throw it away there yeah i
have it i'm chopping my onions there's
just a big bowl
and i'll just put the scraps in there oh
so i don't have to move
if i move then i'm like i'm i'm wasting
too much time
it's this i gotta touch a lot of things
i gotta wipe my hands but if all the
scraps can go in one place
it's just easier and i can stay focused
on just chopping and prepping all that
at once and you just take that and it's
brand new it's fresh
and it's clean too because it's just the
scraps from the the things we're just
cooking
i was able to uh figure out a good flow
of getting things done and making it
exciting
so um because of this whole quarantine
thing and staying home a lot right
it's made it interesting to be able to
tackle on things and figure out an
efficient but fun way of doing it and my
routine has been
doing a physical activity in between
things so for example like let's say i
have a pile of dishes that i need to
deal with
i got some laundry i got these chores i
got to do
and some emails right so i would
probably
get uh my ab roller and then i would do
33 of them in one set and then if i do
33 33 and 34 that's a hundred
so uh while i get going
my blood's flowing whatever and then i
stand up and i'm like okay i need to
breathe
and then i start washing dishes and then
after i'm done with that
then i'll do push-ups and then after
that i'm reading five emails
at a time okay and then i get up so in
between
i'm physically active while i'm getting
[ __ ] done
and it might take longer but it makes it
really fun you get every
everything that you want done yeah yeah
and i'm and then by the time i'm done
with all of my chores
i'm ready i'm warmed up because all that
stuff was like just body weight right
i'm warmed up to lift or doing something
instead of just spending like
15 minutes doing this outside uh i just
do
all of my warm-ups while i'm like doing
chores so my chores are done
i got all my laundry out or i'm folding
it or whatever
and now i'm ready to just freaking lift
and do that part
that's smart yeah cause like if you just
did like say 20 push-ups
every uh first minute of the hour 20
percent takes like a minute yeah right
and then you have an hour break yeah
right it's like 20 seconds
yeah so you have an hour break in
between yeah and it's you're not going
to build a sweat you're not going to get
tired never
get dirty but then just 12 hours it's
240 push-ups that's a lot
volume that's kind of how i was able to
like lose weight during the break and
then like still gain and work out every
day
it's like you're working out less and
then my lifting sessions are only like
40 minutes
because yeah i get all my cardio and all
the other
volume stuff done yeah like i wonder how
good my post would be if i just had
the pull-up bar hanging from my uh
bedroom door if i just every time i
enter an exit just do for two
that's what i did at my house well i
have one now but in my old house
every time i passed through the kitchen
it was ten and i would get like a
thousand done
oh yeah that's a lot yeah throughout the
day though
you know but that's still a lot like
that's a lot of volume that's so good
yeah yeah even uh one of our friends
stan efferding he's like a
like world famous bodybuilder he was
saying a lot of the things for people
that
want to just lose weight and not even
try to get a thousand pull-ups or
whatever but
the first thing he just uh prescribes
is always park in the furthest parking
lot yeah
just start with that you're gonna go to
walmart you're gonna go buy groceries
and do whatever
just park in the fur this one and that
just forces you to walk
like two minutes here five minutes there
and it adds up and you end up walking
like 30 minutes
like a day sometimes though like um when
i am working out too much and i drink
like way too much caffeine
i need to chill out and thank goodness
this video is sponsored by feels
feels thank you feels by the way they
sent me
some nice little cbd oil to chill with i
just put a couple of
them on my tongue and then you know you
do
feel that head change or that chillness
and it's not overpowering to the point
where you're like i can't take this man
this is too crazy
um but it is a it is a way it's a cool
way it's there's no high you know it's
it's a really
chill way of just um transitioning from
that hypeness from working out
to like now it's wind down time
and my sleep has actually been pretty
[ __ ] amazing
like i have a sleep app that i track
i've been doing like eight hours for a
week now
yeah so it's pretty sick man so if
you're new to cbd fields offers a free
cbd hotline to help guide your personal
experience
and feels works naturally to help you
feel better there's no high hangover or
addiction
join the fields community to get fields
delivered to your door every single
month
and you'll save money on every order and
you can pause or cancel at any time
feels has me feeling my best every day
and it can help you too i don't know if
it's just me but i take cbd i get a
boner
become a member today by going to
fields.com off the record and you'll get
50
off your first order with free shipping
that's fuels.com
off the record to become a member and
get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping
fields.com off the record so
uh going back to the whole mental health
thing right like
i think me and you have a very similar
approach when it comes to
these labels or titles like it doesn't
i it doesn't make me who i am it's just
it's kind of like uh
um if if if someone
was you know really good with their
right arm or something or like
the way i put it to my friend was like
i'd like to know if my car
was a all-wheel drive rear-wheel drive
or
or like front wheel drive yeah and
that's kind of how i see
uh like adhd or or certain things like
you know a lot of people will disagree
with me but i don't see it
as a complete disadvantage or an
illness or whatever because there are
good traits that come out of these
things
um for example like if let's say
you are bipolar right like you can
experience these tremendously
like big waves of extreme happiness or
sadness but a lot of
amazing art is created through maybe
some of
this turmoil or whatever and it actually
helps
the rest of us unfortunately their
burden but it helps
the rest of us like you know when they
communicate that so they have these
crazy powers that are
sometimes burdensome but i feel like
there's a lot of beauty in that
superpower like robin williams you know
unfortunately he he he passed away
because he couldn't take what he was
going through
but the joy that he created through that
you know experience is just is just
freaking
crazy it benefited and made so many
people so happy you know
yeah i do think i do think of it mainly
as like a superpower like you said
because like even just watching i think
like you know this day and age there's
so many people with
all kinds of information but i think for
people like
us where we pretty much did our most of
our growing up before the internet
and we kind of had to find our own like
coping mess mechanisms and i realized
like you know someone with adhd
it is pretty hard academically because
it's made for people that are good
at focusing i thought i was dumb as [ __ ]
yeah but then
but then later later on like i found out
that you know people with adhd
are generally very creative and most
people that are very creative just have
adhd that's why they're able to think
outside of the box
so i do think it is kind of like a
superpower and kind of like you where
like
i don't think any label has a
uh general negative tone or positive you
just gotta find the right
key to the keyhole so like if you find
out that your right arm is like super
strong then you can become like an arm
wrestler or
or like a pitcher baseball yeah you got
to figure out your strengths and i think
if our strength is adhd then
we're in the right field like we're in
line with what we
can do which is a creative field or like
we we harness this energy to make
business or whatever
this kind of helped you become
successful for me i think
because we were able to i guess like
figure out a way to work for us i
definitely think it helped us become
successful just because like you know i
think one of the re
a lot of my comedy actually i think
comes from adhd
you know like when people are actually
focused and zone in they're literally
listening to every word
but almost every word that comes out of
someone's mouth
is always this makes me think of this
this makes me think of this so like
when i'm talking to someone i'm actually
having like five conversations at the
same time
so it's easy for me to create jokes and
people think like
uh oh wow bart's like funny or how's he
able to take this and take it to that
direction
i can't even help it it's just someone
says something already makes me think of
10 things
so i think for me because i was able to
figure out this thing called comedy
it actually really helped it help it out
i feel like comedy was almost like a
coping mechanism
because like even like through sad
things or like you were saying just
bringing up stuff
my mind is like creating funny scenarios
in my head but i'm able to listen to you
yeah
i think a lot of creative people might
have some form of it like it's not
um when i was reading this adhd book
right there's
uh there was a survey and there's levels
to the severity of it
and i was like 10 out of 10.
but there's probably some milder form
and in order to tap into that creative
mind you probably
are really you can relate with people
maybe that have adhd
you know it could be i don't know man
but in i think there's a spectrum
yeah i think everyone has a little bit
of something there's just some people
you know some people
like steve you can eat the spiciest food
in the world and
like it doesn't even affect them and
there's some people that eat like
something that's barely spicy and it's
like spicy as a [ __ ] i think
it's like that like everyone probably
has a little bit of adhd and there's
people that have it really bad
but i would say that i don't think that
this made me successful the trait made
me successful or whatever
i think that i was lucky enough to find
something
where um i can thrive in so like
let's say i grew up in a different
country
where i didn't have this option and um
you know like i worked in a company that
required a lot of focus
and just that routine and things that go
against me
i think i would be very unsuccessful and
so like
people will look at me a certain way but
it's like what einstein said right you
can't judge a fish by the way it climbs
a tree
so um i believe that everyone has
really good skills or something that
they can do but they're not in line
with who they are so everyone can
probably thrive
if that was their thing but we're just
in the wrong
seats like like we're like doing the
wrong thing that makes sense yeah
yeah i i think i'm just hella lucky that
i found the thing that
works for me yeah but we do see a stigma
though behind mental health
and like labels and all that especially
when you don't know yourself yet
it is kind of scary like let's say
you're a teen and then you get diagnosed
with adhd or whatever and then you're
told that you can't focus
or you can't do this whenever you're
told you can't do something as a young
person
i think it [ __ ] with their mind because
now they're limiting themselves and
they're like well i'm not gonna study
because you know
i can't focus versus uh me out of
curiosity i just kept going down the
rabbit hole
and then um i was told i was stupid and
unintelligent by you know teachers
and they called my mom saying like i
need to go to special school and all
this [ __ ]
but out of curiosity and just wanting to
learn and going down the rabbit hole and
doing my own research
i was able to uh gain more
understanding of like subjects and
whatever and then i think that if i had
a school for me
i would be able to uh kill it yeah i
think one of the uh
one of the best things that happened to
me was being
sent to the corner because i was always
considered a disruptive student because
they said i can't focus you know like
they'll be like
okay cool um like you know like in
elementary school now it's time to do
this worksheet and you're supposed to be
quiet for 30 minutes right
and i think if you're able to focus you
start doing it but if you're not and
you're like me
then you start like cracking jokes or
you start
crawling under the table or you do like
weird [ __ ] right so i always get in
trouble
and then when my teacher goes bart go to
the corner go to timeout
when i went there and now i was able to
like pluck a staple
out of the carpet now all of a sudden i
could do the worksheet
because now i'm doing like other things
at once you know or i get to like draw
if i could draw like you're distracting
your mind
yeah so now if i'm like if i could draw
here then i could still do the worksheet
or i could like do random [ __ ]
but if i couldn't focus the way they
wanted me to focus which is like
sit in a perfect upright position and do
homework i wasn't able to do that yeah
schools aren't made for all
kids like it's only like a slight few
that actually benefit like that yeah but
what if i was able to sit on the floor
and scribble and do things and i'm like
out of timeout
like the teacher probably thought i knew
the timeout was gonna fix them
but it was actually just because i was
distracted so i was able to do it there
was a
school that i think tested giving all
these kids those fidget toys they had
like a bunch of different buttons on
things
and they said product productivity went
up like crazy grades went up everything
i feel like it goes against human nature
to sit
for hours and focus because um
i don't know maybe i'm just the more
primitive human being and i need to be
playing with branches all day but i i
can't do it
i can't sit especially kids like when
you're like five
imagine what we were like in our
childhood man because that [ __ ] was a
blur
if i can't stay still now [ __ ] dude
i feel bad for my mom taika dude can't
wait because
nuts yeah that's why i think for sure
he's gotta go to private school do you
think he's got adhd
i think so for sure he's he's nuts like
he and what's crazy is he's
yeah he's like me where um like i can't
do one thing
but i can do like five things and by
doing five things i'm actually better at
it he's kind of like that too because
like i'll see him play and stuff and he
puts like a turtle in a random area
and i'm like three hours later i'm like
hey taika do you know where your turtle
is
and i'm thinking he lost it and he goes
it's in the tent i'm like oh [ __ ] so i
think his brain kind of works like mine
where he has to just
he'll do a little bit of stuff over here
a little bit of stuff over there so i
think he for sure has it
[Music]
foreign